how's it goin on this fine Wednesday now
I know repo men is so last weekend but I
wanted to let you guys know about the
collab video I did with the schmoes from
schmoes know cuz they really do know and
for my money which is free to watch on
YouTube they're hilarious they're a
couple of normal guys like you and me
who talk about the same things that
people like let's talk about it okay so
some are going to be season against next
Idol but before you get summer movie you
got to get rid of the rest that spring
crap and so what did we do we went to
the movie theater and we saw repo men
they have good energies to check them
out and you can watch the review of repo
men which features yours truly really is
like like here's a sloppy sloppy show so
I did this video with them because
they're super cool and like I said
they're funny and danielle from jess x
TV on youtube mentioned that we should
collaborate and she's an attractive girl
who talks about sex and the holiday of
course she did so if you like me you'll
probably like them if you think I'm a
prick he'll probably like that so I put
the link in the sidebar go check them
out for some more free hilarity on
YouTube